مرحبا يعطيك العافيه طبعا اليوم هيكون
موضوعنا عن شيء اسمه خرافات غناويه طبعا
زي ما بنعرف اي مجال طبيبي او اي مجال
اييه صحي بالمج
تمع ناس بتدخل وتحاول تعطي معلومات او
تسوي هذه المعلومات وتصير خرافات
وبتنتشر البيبي الناس لكن هي خاطئه انا مش
صحيح
خلونا نعمل مجموعه من
الخرافات
وهل هي صحيحه ام لا اول خرافه بتحكي انه
احنا ما لازم ناكل صفار البيض انه صفار
البيض بيرفع عن الكولسترول عندي في الدم
فبالتالي بتزيد عندي نسبه خطوره الاصابه
طبعا هاي معلومه غلط مش الكعب ليه لانه
كبرت نظيف الانسان
الكولي
سترو لما احنا نتناول البيت راح يرتفع
عندي الكولسترول في الدم فالكبت راح يحرز
كميه اقل من مستويات الطبيعيه بيفرزها
بالعالم فبيصير عندنا بلاويز او تعادل في
المستوى الكولسترول طبعا نسبه قليله جدا
من الناس اللي ممكن انها تتاثر بارتفاع
مستويات الكولسترول في الدم اللي اصلا هم
معرضين جنيه انهم يتاثروا بارتفاع
الكولسترول بشكل
البياض في البروتين والصفار بيحتوي على
البايتامين والمعادن وتكون تحيه المفيده
لعمل الدماغ زي ما بتحكي انه احنا بناخذ
من بعض قليله على فترات طول اليوم هذا
الشيء بيزيد عندي من الحرب
عادي منيحه للناس اللي بيعاني الوجوه عند
المجتمع لكن ما في دراسات تاكدت انه زياده
عدد الوجبات على فترات تكون اليوم بتاثر
على معدل طبعا ثالث اشهر في الراس بتحكي
انه البندوره بتعمل على احتباس
[موسيقى]
المستمر وعدم الحركه والحمل والمشاكل
الهرموني عند النساء او استهلاك همم كميات
عاليه من الصوديوم هاي كلها اسباب تؤدي
الى احتباس السوائل هي احكي لكم معلومه
يعني انه ال 100 جرام من البندوره فيها ما
يعادل 5 ملغم
وما يعادل 37 جنيه من البوتاسيوم يعني
نسبه الصوديوم الموجوده في 100 جرام من
البندوره ما يعادل من واحد الى 48
بوتاسيوم يعني بالعكس البندوره بتعالج لي
موضوع احتباس السوائل ذبح خراف بتحكي انه
دايت العالي بالبروتين يزيد علي بالمحص
الكلى هاي معلومه صحيحه لكن ما بتشمت
تجميع فئات
تشمه جميع الاشخاص
الغذاء هاي فقط لازم يكونوا حاضرين من
الناس بيعاني من امراض الكلى لانه
السلع كمان يعاني من البروتين بيرفع لي
الحمضيات الدم فبالتالي بيرتفع عندي
الكلياتينين في الدم فبياثر على الناس
اللي فعليا عندهم امراض كلى وليس في
العاديه الرياضيين او اشخاص حابين يرفعوا
الفكره العضله يعني اخر فراس بتحكي انه
العدد الفردي من التمر مع بيزيد الوزن
والعدد الزوجي من التمر
فاللي نحكي معلومه انه جسم الانسان متعامل
مع المواد الغذائيه تحرك كيميائيه وليست
حاله الفيزيائيه يعني الاكل لما ينزل على
المعده الانزيمات في الحاضر موجوده داخل
المعده بتحاول انه الى اخر يعني ما في
عداد هو المعنى بعد اذنك او شيء ومن
خلالها
[موسيقى]